these are nachos
golden crispy chips gooey melted cheese
mounds of toppings galore they are
delicious
they're named after a man a man named
nacho
this was Ignacio Anaya known to friends
and foes alike as nacho in 1943 Ignacio
was a Maitre D' at this restaurant the
old victory club Piedras Negras Mexico a
border town of jalapenos through from
Eagle Pass Texas home of Fort Duncan an
army base filled with military men and
families one day a group of Army wives
crossed the border they shopped they got
hungry they went to the victory Club the
chef wasn't there but Ignacio Maitre D'
didn't want to turn the women away so he
sprang into action
grabbing tortillas shredded cheddar
cheese and jalapenos put his creation
into the oven pensively
he served to the army wives they loved
attorney to Texas they spread the ELN
jelly Odelle nacho the gospel of the
nacho nacho specially ally oz became so
adored and renowned Ignacio opened up
his own restaurant
the creatively named nachos restaurant